VICTOR DAVIS HANSON: It's
a great question today
that we ponder.
Was it worth it?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There's a couple of things
to remember about air power
before we begin in earnest.
One is that there was an
enormous transformation
between its inaugural appearance
in 1914 in World War I
when pilots and biplanes
shot revolvers at each other.
In less than 30 years--
about 25 years, 24 years--
at the outbreak in September
1, 1939 in World War II,
we had monoplanes,
and the speeds
had increased from 100
miles an hour to nearly 300.
And people were firing
about 700 to 800 shots
per minute on machine
guns, sometimes
right through the propeller,
sometimes on the wings.
And they were
carrying bomb loads
in the case of fire bombers
of 500 to 1,000 pounds
and bombers even far greater.
So there was a
miraculous transformation
in the role of air power.
And that created our
architects of air power,
so to speak, in the
European countries
and in the United
States as well--
Billy Mitchell, Douhet,
Weaver in Germany.
And they were so enthralled
by this new weapon
that they made a series
of astounding predictions,
so much that Prime
Minister Stanley
Baldwin in the late 1930s said
in despair, the bomber will
always get through.
And it was almost as if assets
at sea, navies, and assets
on the ground, infantry,
were going to be
secondary or even irrelevant.
The war would take
place up in the air.
The problem with that is
nobody lives up in the air.
Nobody eats in the air.
Nobody can fly.
We don't have wings.
So what you're doing is
transferring labor and capital
from the ground up into the air.
And there has to be
a purpose for that.
And the purpose had to be
either air superiority or air
supremacy.
And by that I mean,
your air forces
had to beat the other person's
air forces for the prime reason
that they could then direct
their assets to where things
really mattered on the ground--
taking cities or territory
or killing people
or capturing them on the ground.
If you couldn't do that, and
you only achieved air parity,
then both sides were sort
of wasting their time
in an irrelevant theater.
So the purpose was to build
more planes and better planes
and train better pilots to
destroy the enemy's air assets
or at least weaken them so
you had air superiority.
And then, the holy
grail was air supremacy.
That meant that you could put
your assets up in the air,
they could fly over the enemy's
territory, destroy his cities
or his armies on the ground,
and they would be invulnerable
because you had destroyed
the enemy's ability
to fight back in the air.
And that was pretty
much the theory
of air power in World War II.
It's a great question today
that we ponder, was it worth it?
The people say it didn't work.
80,000 people weren't worth it.
We lost over 5,000
bomber planes.
We spent 40% of our
military budget.
And yet, German industrial
production kept going.
The defenders of air
power said, well,
we had to make the
necessary investments.
We lost men and
material learning
how to fly in the
proper formation,
how to have the proper
fighter, the proper fighter
tactics, the proper radar.
But once we learned that,
we destroyed Germany's
industrial production.
And it's not quite
accurate to say
it continued to increase in
terms of vehicle or aircraft
production because Germany
really wasn't mobilized
until Albert Speer, the
tsar of German industry,
took control over the
economy in late 1943.
Once he did that,
we were destroying
the increase in production.
And Speer's planned economy
was not sustainable.
So even though it increased,
it did not increase at the rate
that it would otherwise
have had we not been
bombing around the clock.
The United States lost
about 400,000 dead
through accidents,
disease, and combat.
Britain lost a little bit
fewer and yet defeated
a far more formidable
enemy than was
true in World War
I. In other words,
Germany, Japan, and Italy
were far more powerful allies
and enemies than had
been the Imperial German
Army of World War I.
And how did they do that?
And how did they lose
only about 2% to 3%
of their entire military forces?
And the answer was sea power
and air power did one thing--
they avoided the need
to land in Europe
at the very beginning of 1940,
'41 in the case of British
and the United States
in '42 or '43 in Japan.
In other words,
we did not do what
we did in 1917 in
the case of America
and the British in 1914.
We did not bleed white
our ground forces
to take the enemy capital and
knock the enemy out of the war.
We bombed them into submission
and therefore precluded
an invasion of Japan entirely.
And we precluded an
invasion of Europe
until we were ready
to do it in June 1944.
So the ultimate verdict,
I think, on air power
was it was very
costly, it did not
work too well in
'41, '42, and '43,
but the Allies
gained the lessons
and achieved air superiority and
eventually air supremacy that
by 1944, 1945, it saved
thousands of lives.
And it was one of the greatest
successes of World War II.
SPEAKER 2: Thank
you for watching.
We hope you're enjoying
our Highlights series
and invite you to explore our
complete course on the Second
World Wars.
All of Hillsdale
College's online courses
are free and for everyone
who loves to learn.